Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nr. 33. Lange nichts mehr gehört vom Chaosradio. Habt ihr einen Monat Pause? Ich bin ein bisschen unterwegs gewesen, hier und da, aber es gab ja Beiträge bei Chaosradio International in englischer Sprache, der Schwesterkanal von Chaosradio Express und außerdem ist auch nächsten Mittwoch schon wieder die neue Chaosradio 114 zum Thema Software-Projektmanagement. Heute geht es um KDE, das K Desktop Environment. Zu Gast ist Sebastian Kügler und mein Name, wie gewohnt, ist Tim Pritlove. Ja, hier ist Chaosradio wieder und ich sage Hallo zu Sebastian. Hallo Sebastian.
Hallo Tim.
Wunderbar. Ja, wir sind, das habe ich noch gar nicht erwähnt, wir befinden uns gerade auf der Froscon, der Free-and-Open-Source-Software-Konferenz hier in St. Augustin in der Nähe von Bonn. Das ist eine neue junge Veranstaltung, die sich der Open-Source-Entwicklung thematisch zugewendet hat. Das geht hier über zwei Tage, über das Wochenende und ist eigentlich gut angelaufen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir gefallen hat bisher.
Es ist ein sehr relaxter Event, es ist tolles Wetter, die Leute sind super. Die Organisation ist einfach nur klasse und es macht eine Menge Spaß, sich mit den Leuten hier zu unterhalten.
Ja, das sehe ich auch. Also hier ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge gute Vorarbeit geleistet worden und ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher, dass hier schon für die Nachfolgeveranstaltung geplant wird. Ja, wir haben uns jetzt hier getroffen und ich bin ganz froh, dass wir hier zum Gespräch kommen zu einem Thema, was ich schon längere auf meiner Liste habe, nämlich KDE, das K Desktop Environment, ein freier Desktop für Open Source Betriebssysteme, vielleicht auch für andere Systeme, das weiß ich nicht, aber du kannst mir da sehr viel mehr zu sagen, denn du bist ja in der Entwicklung, aber auch vor allem in der Evangelisierung von KDE selber aktiv tätig. Du bist, wie ich das richtig sehe, Teil der sogenannten Marketing Working Group von KDE. Kannst du das mal ein bisschen ausführen, was da organisatorisch dahinter steht und wie du da deine eigene Rolle definierst?
Ja, natürlich. Also KDE ist ein großes Open Source Projekt und es gibt einige organisationelle Dinge, die da halt geregelt werden müssten. Sachen wie Trademarks, Webdomains, sowas alles. Und da braucht man halt eine Organisation für. Das ist der KDEV, also das ist ein deutscher eingetragener Verein, der sich um die Belange von KDE international kümmert. Der KDEV hat im letzten Jahr beschlossen, also in der Mitgliederversammlung beschlossen, drei Arbeitsgruppen einzurichten. Das ist die Technical Working Group, die kümmert sich um Release Management, was muss in die Software, was kann rein, wann sind Releases fertig und reif. Dann gibt es die Human Computer Interface Working Group. Da sitzen Usability-Leute, die sich darum kümmern, dass das User Interface halt brauchbar ist. Da sitzen Künstler, die sich um Artwork, wie Icons, Wallpapers und Farbzusammenstellungen des Desktops kümmern, dass es halt schön aussieht. Und da sitzen Accessibility-Leute, die sich darum kümmern, dass es auch für Behinderte zugänglich ist, dass blinde Leute den Computer genauso benutzen können, wie scheinbar normale Menschen auch.
Genau, da arbeitet ihr auch wahrscheinlich mit Gruppen zusammen, wie zum Beispiel Open Usability, die sehr aktiv sind.
Richtig, Open Usability sind unsere Freunde. Und dann gibt es halt die Marketing Working Group, und die habe ich seit letztem Sommer geholfen aufzubauen, zusammen mit noch zwei anderen Kollegen. Und wir kommen uns halt darum, dass strukturell eigentlich Sachen passieren, die ansonsten schnell unter den Tisch fallen, dass zum Beispiel Press-Releases rauskommen. Aber auch, dass über Strategie nachgedacht wird. Es sind einfache Sachen wie Merchandising für Events, auf denen wir auftreten. Aber es sind auch Sachen wie Nachdenken über Zielgruppen, was wollen wir eigentlich erreichen? Nicht nur in den nächsten drei Wochen, sondern auch in den nächsten fünf Jahren. Da kommen ziemlich viele verschiedene Sachen eigentlich nach oben, wo wir viel Arbeit reinstecken müssen, aber die auch wahnsinnig viel Spaß machen, weil es halt sehr, sehr breit gefächert ist.
Wie muss man mir das vorstellen? Also wie viele Leute machen diese Working Group aus und wie sind die verteilt?
Also wir haben eigentlich ein Kernteam von drei Leuten, die halt offiziell die Rolle der Working Group wahrnehmen und drum herum bilden wir ein Team und da drum herum wieder eine Community. Also die Marketing Working Group besteht aus drei Leuten. Das Marketing Team sind in etwa zehn bis zwölf. Das sind Leute, die sich lieber auf etwas strategischerem, organisatorischem Niveau beschäftigen und die auch längerfristig ein bisschen Zeit haben, um sich damit zu befassen. Und dann gibt es die etwas breitere Community von Leuten, die ab und an Zeit haben, uns zu helfen. Und wir versuchen halt, diese ganze Blase, die da um diese Fragen entsteht, zu koordinieren.
Das heißt, das Ganze ist auch der Versuch, so ein bisschen Struktur ins Chaos zu bekommen. Ich nehme mal an, ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau, aber ich nehme einfach mal an, dass sehr viele Leute aus diesen Working Groups aus Europa, wenn nicht sogar aus Deutschland kommen, weil ja hier ganz klar ein Schwerpunkt ist. Denn KDE ist ja im Prinzip ein deutsches Kind. Das ist vor zehn Jahren gegründet worden. Wie ist der junge Mann Matthias Etrich hat das losgetreten. Kannst du da ein bisschen mal Einblick geben, weil es ja eigentlich ungewöhnlich ist, dass eigentlich ein Open-Source-Projekt aus Deutschland so breite Bedeutung erlangt hat.
Also der Matthias, der hat am 14. Oktober vor zehn Jahren eine E-Mail geschrieben an die Community und gesagt, dass er satt ist, dass alles auf Unix und freien Betriebssystemen total auseinander wächst und hat versucht, das zu konsolidieren. Und hat halt Leute gesucht, die ihm dabei helfen. Und das ist dann geschehen, ganz kurz sind in den nächsten Jahren bis jetzt drei verschiedene große Versionen rausgekommen. Matthias hatte sich damals dafür entschieden, das Qt-Toolkit von der Firma Trolltech dafür zu benutzen, weil das halt eine sehr high level Interface bietet, um Anwendungen zu programmieren. Das geht dann halt von User-Interface-Elementen bis zu Sachen, die Zugriff auf Daten erlauben, Datenstrukturen und so was alles. Und auf diesem Qt-Toolkit baut KDE auf. KDE besteht aus mehreren Layern, zum Beispiel die KDE-Libs, die viele Sachen aus dem Qt-Toolkit zusammenfassen. Bei KDE-Libs kann man sich zum Beispiel den File-Open-Dialog von allen KDE-Anwendungen vorstellen, aber auch Elemente wie ein Fenster, das bestimmtes Input erlaubt.
Genau, da sollten wir vielleicht noch mal erst mal so ein bisschen erklären, worum es eigentlich geht. Also KDE steht für K Desktop Environment. Ich glaube, am Anfang stand das K mal für cool, aber das wurde dann wahrscheinlich, weil es uncool war, gestrichen und auf K reduziert, dass man sich so einen Buchstaben herausnimmt, der dann auch die ganze Außendarstellung dominiert. Das ist ja bei Unix nichts Ungewöhnliches. Das hat man ja vorher mit X-Windows schon gesehen. Aber ich denke, in dem Kontext ist das auch zu sehen. Aber es gibt halt sehr viele Programme, die mit K anfangen. Und wenn sie nicht mit K anfangen, dann hören sie meistens mit K auf. Aber es geht halt um ein Desktop Environment. Also im Prinzip die Antwort jenseits des Fensters, wie interagiert der Computer mit dem Benutzer. Und es geht dabei eben auch generell um die Definition von Benutzerschnittstellen. Ich habe immer so den Eindruck gehabt, dass sich KDE sehr an Windows orientiert hat. Würdest du dem zustimmen?
Ich habe mir den Eindruck, dass sich die Developer zu wenig Gedanken machen, wie dieses Rohprodukt KDE eigentlich aussehen sollte. Ich kann mir KDE einrichten, wie ich es haben will. Das ist größtenteils eigentlich eine Sache, die erwartet man vielleicht von einer Distribution, dass GUI-Elemente anders angeordnet werden. Also KDE ist bis ins kleinste Detail konfigurierbar. Das heißt, ich kann es mir so einrichten, dass es reagiert wie ein OSX-System, dass es ähnlich aussieht. Aber ich kann es mir auch so einrichten, dass man den Unterschied zu einem XP-System kaum mehr sieht. Und wie man das haben will, also die Philosophie, die dahintersteckt, ist eigentlich, dass man dem User die Wahl lassen will. Und dass man auch eigentlich nicht direkt ein fertiges Produkt schafft, sondern ein Framework. KDE definiert sich nicht nur als Software, als Desktop Environment, sondern auch als Entwicklungsplattform. Das heißt, dass ich mir als Software-Entwickler, wenn ich ein bestimmtes Tool entwickeln will, die Sache vereinfachen kann, wenn ich KDE benutze. Das heißt, ich bekomme bestimmte Sachen. Zum Beispiel ein Übersetzungs-Framework kann ich sehr einfach einbauen. Das heißt, mein Tool oder meine Applikation kann in verschiedenen Sprachen übersetzt laufen. Dann Standard-User-Interface-Elemente, dass die komplette Umgebung konsistent aussieht. Kommunikationsmechanismen mit anderen Programmen sind sehr wichtig. Dann Tastenkürzel, die sich mit dem ganzen Desktop vertragen.
Es gibt große Probleme auf allen Plattformen immer.
Richtig. Und dieses ganze Framework, diese Plattform, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Teil von KDE. Und das ist, denke ich, auch die Kraft von KDE. Das macht es sehr einfach und komfortabel für Entwickler, damit zu arbeiten.
Der Großteil von KDE ist ja in C++ programmiert. Genauso wie diese QT-Library, die ja im Prinzip eine C++-Framework ist, wie du auch schon hingewiesen hast. Ich finde das insofern einen bemerkenswerten Unterschied, weil viele denken immer, da gibt es eine Library und damit kann man das machen. Aber so ein Framework verhält sich ja anders. Bei KDE ist es ja auch so, dass die Programme im Prinzip die ganze Fähigkeit erben, aus einem bestehenden Kraftpaket, was man einfach nur noch weiterverwendet, indem man neue Funktionalitäten zufügt. Insofern ist KDE eigentlich auch das System, was dem Mac zum Beispiel am nächsten ist. Bei Mac OS X zieht eigentlich seine ganze Kraft aus dieser Framework-Idee, was viele Leute immer nicht so auf den ersten Blick auch wahrnehmen. Im Gegensatz zu Windows, wo das eben alles über eine längere Zeit sehr viel mehr über prozedurale Interfaces geht. Ich meine, auch dort tut sich eine ganze Menge. Da kann man vielleicht auch nachher noch mal kurz auf Mono oder so was zu sprechen kommen. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt unbedingt C++ programmieren muss, um eine Anwendung unter KDE zu schreiben, oder?
Nein, das ist richtig. Und C++ ist eigentlich eine relativ komplexe Sprache, die bestimmte Vorteile bietet, aber nicht unbedingt immer das beste Werkzeug für eine bestimmte Aufgabe ist. Wir haben uns in letzter Zeit sehr darauf konzentriert, um KDE-Entwicklung auch für Nicht-C++-Entwickler zu öffnen. Ich glaube, das beste Beispiel dafür sind die Python-Bindings. PyKDE ist ein Framework oder eine Python-Library, mit der man in Python komplette C++-Programme programmieren kann.
Also komplette KDE-Programme.
Komplette KDE-Programme, richtig. Und der Trick ist eigentlich, dass fast alles im C++-Code passiert, dass Python eigentlich nur benutzt wird, um die KDE-Elemente zusammen zu skripten, wenn man es so will. Das heißt, die Programme fühlen sich genauso an wie C++-Programme. Die kritischen Sachen, die sich wirklich auf Performance auswirken, wie zum Beispiel das Zeichnen der User-Interface-Elemente, die finden im C++-kompilierten Code statt und sind deswegen genauso schnell.
Du sagst irgendwie populäre Beispiele von Programmen, die in Peißen programmiert sind, die so in breiter Verwendung sind oder ist das eher so der vertikale Markt, wo man sich so seine eigene Lösung für irgendwas bastelt?
Eigentlich beides. Also, dass es eine gute Gelegenheit für mich, um Reklame für meine eigene Software zu machen. Als Marketing-Dude muss ich das natürlich jetzt mal...
Okay, dann schalten wir jetzt mal den Werbeteil ein.
Guidance ist ein Set System-Administrationstools. Und was wir gemacht haben, ist, wir haben...
Guidance.
Guidance, ja.
Ohne K.
Ja, richtig. Kommen wir vielleicht später noch darauf zurück auf diese K-Hölle. Guidance hat eigentlich zwei Layer, eine Bibliothek, mit der man systemnah arbeiten kann. Das heißt, bestimmte... Wir nehmen mal als Beispiel ein Tool zur Benutzer-Konfiguration. Wir können zum Beispiel das Unix-Benutzer Backend-Pam über eine Guidance-Python-Library benutzen und diese Library wieder über ein in Python programmiertes User-Interface. Wir haben das mal durchgemessen. Wir sparen ungefähr 90 Prozent der Menge an Code. Wir haben keine Probleme mit...
Gegenüber welcher Lösung?
Gegenüber einer vergleichbaren C++-Lösung.
Also im Sinne von Code, im Sinne von der Anzahl der Zeilen, die man schreibt?
Ja, richtig. Einfach die Menge Source-Code. Wir haben keine Probleme mit Memory Leaks, zumindest nicht auf dem Level. Und es lässt sich wesentlich einfacher auch für... Also die meisten C++-Entwickler können Python, aber es ist leider nicht umgekehrt. Das heißt, wir öffnen durch die Entwicklung in Python viele Leute, die sich nicht mehr C++ auseinandersetzen können oder wollen oder denen es zu viel Arbeit ist.
Und die es auch einfach gar nicht müssen, weil wenn man sowieso die gleiche Mächtigkeit hat, was sollte man dann eben noch...
Ja, richtig.
Und wenn es nicht nötig ist?
Und die Sprache bietet halt mehr Features, sodass man einfacher und wesentlich schneller Programme entwickeln kann. Und ich würde sagen, für 80 bis 90 % der Use-Cases ist Python die bessere Wahl. Einige Sachen will man halt nicht in Python machen. Da kann man immer noch C++ für benutzen. Das sind vor allem performance-kritische Sachen. Aber die Möglichkeit, sich da zu entscheiden, die ist natürlich noch immer gegeben. Es hat im Grunde genommen den Effekt, dass es schnellere Applikationsentwicklungen erlaubt, dass es mehr Leuten erlaubt, Applikationen zu entwickeln und damit natürlich zur Verbesserung der Software.
Ja, im Prinzip auch sichere Software machen, weil C++ natürlich auch immer das Problem hat mit den üblichen Problematiken, die wir alle kennen, auch wenn das natürlich auf dem Desktop-Bereich nicht unbedingt jetzt so ein verbreitetes Problem ist.
Richtig, und was auch wichtig ist, dass man es nicht kompilieren muss. Das heißt, wir können ein Python-Programm in einem Skript für verschiedene Architekturen ausliefern.
Richtig, das ist quasi auch Open Source by Design. Ja, klar. Genauso wie bei JavaScript zum Beispiel im Web oder auch generell natürlich schon HTML, aber in Bezug auf Coding ist ja auch JavaScript im Prinzip eine ideale Open Source-Sprache. Nicht, dass jetzt jeder das lesen kann, was Google Maps so an JavaScript ausspricht, aber generell wird natürlich auch hier die Nachahmungskultur noch weiter bereichert mit Peißen. Das sehe ich auf jeden Fall genauso. Das heißt, es gibt, um es zusammenzufassen, wir haben jetzt irgendwie 10 Jahre KDE, es gab verschiedene Releases, wir sind derzeit bei 3.5.3. 3.5.3, das heißt, das ist quasi die Versionsnummer für ein Sammelsurium von Software, was man sich auf seinem Rechner installieren kann. Da kann man gleich nochmal sagen, was die einfachsten Wege dazu sind, aber nur um es nochmal zu verstehen, was quasi einem normalen Unix-Betriebssystem, also Linux, BSD, you name it, im Prinzip alle Varianten, einen Desktop beschert, man kann sich einloggen, man hat irgendwie die Idee eines Benutzer-Environments, man kann Programme-Grafe starten, so wie man das eben von Windows oder von Mac her auch gewohnt ist und auch mit einem ähnlichen Appeal. Also es geht eigentlich nur um die Standardidee des Windows-Environments. Wo würdest du denn sagen, ist KDE dann vielleicht vorne, weil man gerade so in der Diskussion mit, im Vergleich mit dem Macintosh, ich war die Macintosh-Gemeinde, die hat ja da immer so ihr Lächeln übrig für die Anstrengungen im Open-Source-Bereich, aber es gibt ja sicherlich auch Gegenbeispiele, siehst du irgendwo die Nase vorne?
Auf jeden Fall im Bereich Community, da ist Open-Source besonders stark. Also es gibt eine Menge Mindshare, dass Software frei sein sollte, dass man seine Lieblingsprogramme mit anderen teilen kann. Das ist für uns ganz wichtig. Dann, was ich gerade schon angesprochen hatte, das starke Development-Framework, was einfach erlaubt, sehr kraftvolle Applikationen zu entwickeln. Und dann für den Benutzer eine sehr weitgehende Integration. Wir haben das K-Wallet, das ist ein Programm, das speichert für alle anderen Desktop-Programme Passwörter. Das geht vom Instant-Messaging-Programm über Formulare in Webseiten, Passwörter für den Mail-Plant. Alles wird in einem Programm gespeichert. Das heißt, ich brauche nicht in 20 Programmen die Passwörter zu löschen, wenn ich meinen Computer sauber machen will.
Also das, was man vom Mac her kennt, von der Keychain. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Windows über sowas auch verfügt.
Ich weiß es auch. Ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Ich benutze weder OS X noch Apple.
Apple hat das schon relativ lange. Wenn es nicht nutzbar ist, ist es eigentlich erst seit Mac OS X. Aber das ist schon fein. Das ist wichtig. Die Idee der Frameworks zeigt sich halt immer wieder, dass man relativ wenig neu hinzuproagieren muss. Gibt es jetzt irgendwo einen Bereich, wo du sagen würdest, da sind jetzt auch die Anwendungen besonders stark?
Also traditionell natürlich im Bereich Softwareentwicklung. Alles, was mit Netzwerk zu tun hat, ist in KDE sehr stark. Und da gibt es einen guten Grund für das, nämlich die Kommunikation mit Netzwerkprotokollen nur einmal implementiert ist und sehr einfach benutzbar ist für alle Anwendungen. Wenn ich zum Beispiel meine Website bearbeiten will, ich habe jetzt zufällig gerade kein Content-Management-System, dann öffne ich einfach mein HTML-Editor-Programm und öffne die Dateien auf dem Webserver direkt. Öffne sie, bearbeite sie und speichere sie wieder ab und es landet direkt wieder auf dem Webserver.
Also öffnen heißt, dass der File-Open-Dialog, also dieses Dialogfenster, was normalerweise immer hochkommt, quasi auch gleich das Netzwerk mit eingebaut hat.
Es lädt runter, bearbeitet und lädt automatisch wieder hoch. Und das passiert halt mit dem Öffnen- und Speichern-Knopf. Ich denke, für mehr als 50 Protokolle kann ich diesen Mechanismus direkt benutzen. Also so Klassiker wie FTP, HTTP, WebDAF, ähnlicher Mechanismus wird für Archiv-Dateien benutzt. Das heißt, ich brauche zum Beispiel auch nicht ein Archiv erst auspacken, sondern ich klicke einfach das Archiv offen, öffne die Datei, bearbeite sie, speichere sie wieder ab und im Hintergrund wird die...
Das heißt, man schaut quasi nur in eine ZIP-Datei rein, greift auf seine Datei drin zu, ohne das vorher auspacken zu müssen.
Richtig, also es ist voll transparent. Dann natürlich die Integration und das Teilen der verschiedenen Komponenten. Das ganze Open Source-Modell macht wahnsinnig viel Sinn, wenn man eine konsistente Erfahrung für den Benutzer haben will. Weil alles wird geteilt, Open Source-Entwickler sind wahnsinnig faul. Wenn man hier zum Fenster rausguckt, dann sieht man das bestätigt. Das heißt, man will nichts zweimal programmieren. Das heißt, man teilt sich die Sachen. Das heißt, die Sachen sehen auch überall, wenn ich jetzt eine bestimmte Komponente benutze, dann ist die auch überall gleich. Ich kopiere die nicht und ändere sie. Sondern ich überlege mir, wie können wir da den gemeinsamen Weg finden?
Ja, jetzt ist es ja so, dass KDE aber nicht die einzige Lösung ist. Am Anfang ist das ja auch etwas ruppig gestartet. Also dieser Wunsch, erstmal das Desktop Environment zu haben, ist dann von der Open Source-Gemeinde mit viel Geschrei begleitet worden, weil eben QT, auf der ja alles aufbaut, also dieses Framework von der Firma Trolltech aus Norwegen, nicht im eigentlichen Sinne freie Software war, also zumindest nicht unter der GPL lizenziert war. Und das hat dann zunächst einmal eine Gegenbewegung losgetreten, die dann später zur Entwicklung von GNOME führte. Und GNOME ist ja im Prinzip ein Projekt, das exakt dieselben Ziele hat, wie eigentlich KDE auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da irgendwelche Unterschiede siehst, bei dem Ansatz, den GNOME verfolgt. Aber im Prinzip geht es dort halt auch um ein Desktop Environment, um die Definition von User Interface. Und man hat jetzt quasi die Situation, dass alles doppelt gemacht wird. Und es irgendwie derzeit auch nicht so richtig abzusehen ist, was da jetzt den Schritt nach vorne macht und vielleicht das andere ersetzt oder wiegen. Also das würde mich mal auch interessieren, wie das in der KDE-Gemeinde selber eigentlich gesehen wird, diese Entwicklung, wie sie bisher war und was da in Zukunft erwartet wird.
Also ich glaube, der Unterschied zwischen KDE und GNOME, den man als Benutzer als erstes wahrnimmt, ist, dass KDE einem eigentlich alles erlauben will und das führt natürlich zu einem eventuellen Überfluss an Möglichkeiten für die meisten Entwickler. Das heißt, wir müssen da sehr viel tun, um die Interfaces glatt zu bügeln, dass man halt nichts einstellen braucht, aber dass man es kann. Und in der GNOME-Welt werden die Optionen eigentlich einfach aus dem User-Interface gestrichen.
Da seit GNOME 2.0 ist da vor allem so ein ganz spürbarer Bruch gewesen, da haben sie wirklich viel aufgeräumt.
Beide Environments legen sehr viel Wert auf Benutzerfreundlichkeit. Eigentlich eine Sache, die traditionell in der Open-Source-Gemeinde lange vernachlässigt wurde, aber die Ansätze sind sehr unterschiedlich. In Gnome, wenn ich bestimmte Einstellungen ändern will, dann habe ich nicht direkt die Möglichkeit, das aus dem grafischen User-Interface zu machen, aber ich kann es in einer Art Registry immer noch ändern. Und KDE ist halt der Ansatz, etwas mehr Sachen zuzulassen. Das heißt, ich kann mir mehr Sachen einstellen. Das ist toll für Power-User. Man muss aber dann auch sehen, dass man nicht erst eine halbe Stunde Sachen einstellen muss, bevor man was einfach benutzen kann. Das heißt, wir müssen die Voreinstellungen mindestens dreimal nachgucken und richtig setzen. Dann ist natürlich ein riesengroßer Unterschied im Entwicklungs-Framework. Gnome ist weit weniger modulär aufgebaut. Die Basis von Gnome bietet Entwicklern lange nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, um sehr schnell, sehr kraftvolle Applikationen zu entwickeln. Das ist teilweise ein Effekt der Programmiersprache, aber das ist auch ein Ansatz, das in KDE in den letzten Jahren sehr viel am Framework gearbeitet worden ist. Der Release-Cycle, der zum Release von KDE 3 geleitet hat, war wirklich ein Framework-Release-Cycle. Es sind Techniken erstellt worden, oder Technologien erstellt worden, die sehr einfach Zugriff auf Dateien im Netzwerk erlauben. Frameworks zur Kommunikation zwischen verschiedenen Programmen, alle solche Sachen. Und die haben dazu geleitet, dass man auf sehr hohem Niveau Applikationen programmieren kann. Und ich denke, dass das GNOME, ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich kein erfahrener GNOME-Entwickler bin. Ich aber sehr gerne mit GNOME-Leuten Bier trinke zum Beispiel. Bei GNOME muss man etwas mehr dieser Sachen noch selber machen. Also es ist nicht so, dass das High-Level-Programmieren, was man sich vorstellen kann.
Es wird ja auch ein etwas anderer Ansatz dort gepflegt. Also die Programmiersprache der Wahl bei GNOME ist C tatsächlich. Aber es gibt halt dann dieses G-Object-System, was Objektorientierung auf dem niedrigsten Level macht. Also mit der Intention, eben verschiedene Programmiersprachen, gleiche Zutrittsschancen zu gewähren. Jetzt ist es halt so, dass bei KDE im Wesentlichen C++ da vorne ist. Aber eben, wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen, gerade eben über diese populären Scriptsprachen, wie zum Beispiel Python. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es auch ein Binding für Pearl zum Beispiel oder für Ruby?
Für Ruby gibt es tolle Bindings. Der Richard Dale, der im Moment auf Tenerife arbeitet, steckt sehr viel Arbeit in einen generischen Mechanismus, um Bindings zu bauen.
Also das ist dieselbe Verheiratung wie mit Python, die jetzt schon existiert.
Ja, Python ist die erwachsenste Bindings-Sache. Der Richard Dale arbeitet halt daran, diese C++-Bibliotheken zu öffnen für alle möglichen Sprachen. Dass man sehr einfach Ruby-Bindings generieren kann, dass man mit sehr wenig Arbeit pearl, dass man einfach die Sprache benutzt, die man will, und die Bindings generiert.
Ich denke, dass da auch eine große Zukunft drin liegt in diesen Script-Sprachen. Weil natürlich tatsächlich gerade auf dem Desktop geht es ja eigentlich darum, zu vereinfachen, zusammenzufassen und konsistente Benutzer-Ergebnisse zu bringen. Das heißt, man will ja explizit auch viel neu benutzen. Man will sehr viel wieder verwenden und dafür dann unter Umständen noch ein einfacheres oder eben im Einzelfall auch komplexeres User-Interface bauen für einen bestimmten Fall. Aber man will halt nicht immer wieder komplett bei A bis Z anfangen. Wir hatten, glaube ich, vorhin auch kurz gesprochen über CD-Brennen. Das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Beispiel von einer System-Funktionalität von KDE, die man eben als Programmierer dann einfach aufnehmen kann, auch wenn es dafür halt schon ein populäres Tool gibt. Wie hieß das noch gleich? K3b?
Richtig, K3b. Und alle KDE-Applikationen kann man von außen ansprechen über ein Scripting-Interface. Das ist ein Mechanismus, der heißt DCOP. Und in der Zukunft wird das geändert nach Dibas. Da kommen wir, glaube ich, später nochmal drauf zurück. Aber mit DCOP kann ich ein Programm sagen, was es machen muss. Das heißt, ich kann ein Skript schreiben, was ein laufendes Programm beeinflusst. In diesem Fall kann ich zum Beispiel ein Skript schreiben, was ganz einfach eine ISO-Datei an K3b weiterreicht. K3b brennt mir das. Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Backup-Applikation schreiben will und ich will die Daten auf CD haben, dann ist das keine Arbeit im Grunde genommen.
Ist es jetzt, dass K3b quasi die Brennfunktionalität macht oder ist K3b auch nur ein User-Interface für eine Brennfunktionalität, die auf Framework-Level da ist?
K3b ist auch wieder nur ein User-Interface. Im Hintergrund benutzt K3b CD-Record und ist halt ein grafisches User-Interface, aber gleichzeitig auch ein Scripting-Interface für diesen KDE-IPC-Mechanismus, das Inter-Prozesskommunikation. Richtig. Und ein anderes Beispiel für diesen IPC-Mechanismus ist zum Beispiel ein Instant-Messaging-Programm, Kopit, und ein Mail-Client. Es kann sehr sinnvoll sein, wenn die sich ab und zu mal unterhalten, wenn sie zum Beispiel Adressdaten austauschen wollen. Wenn ich eine Mail in meinen Mail-Client einblende und ich möchte da schnell darauf reagieren, dann blendet mein Mail-Client ein, ob der Benutzer, der mir die Mail geschickt hat, gerade online ist im ICQ oder Java. Und was macht Kamel da im Hintergrund eigentlich? Das schickt ganz einfach eine Message an Kopit, sagt, er ist seit Tim online, Kopit sagt, ja, der ist gerade online, aber der ist auch gerade away, weil er gerade einen Podcast mit Sebastian aufnimmt. Solche Sachen machen die Arbeit mit dem Desktop sehr einfach. Warum geht es ja auch? Richtig. Ein weiteres Beispiel ist, dass ich im File Manager ganz einfach rechts klicken kann und sagen kann, verschickt das an einen bestimmten Benutzer. Ich frage das Adressbuch, wie kann ich den Benutzer erreichen? Das Adressbuch weiß ich nicht. Ich kann ihm eine Mail schicken, weil ich habe die Mail-Adresse. Der ist aber auch gerade im ICQ, im Jabber online. Das heißt, ich könnte ihm auch das File so direkt rüber schicken. Ich gebe dir gleich eine CD.
Ja, da kann man auch gleich nochmal dazu sagen. Es gibt natürlich auch fertige Distributionen, wo KDE mit dabei ist. Vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang ganz interessant. Ich habe das auf dem Lienungstag nebenbei mitbekommen. Der Lienungstag ist ja ein bisschen wie ein Heimspiel von der KDE-Gemeinde, hatte ich immer bisher so den Eindruck. Weil Deutschland, weil hier das Projekt auch geboren wurde, der Schwerpunkt der KDE-Entwicklung ist. Es gibt hier sehr viele Entwickler, die gibt es natürlich auch weltweit. Aber es ist schon ganz klar, dass die ganze Genome-Entwicklung sehr viel mehr in Amerika angesiedelt ist. Von daher ist es auch so ein bisschen ein Wettbewerb der Kulturen an der Stelle. Interessante Ergebnisse. Dort auf dem Lienungstag war ja Mark Shuttleworths eingeladen, von dem Ubuntu-Projekt, derzeit eine der am meisten staubaufwirbelnden Distributionsprojekte im Lienungsbereich. Und das Ubuntu-Projekt gab es ja schon immer in zwei Varianten. Es gab das Ubuntu, mit dem sie gestartet sind, was eben mit Gnomen gearbeitet hat, und dann gab es Kubuntu, was dann eben mit KDE zusammen gearbeitet hat. Aber wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, gab es doch jetzt auch wieder eine, hat er ja so angekündigt, dass KDE und Gnomen in der nächsten Zukunft gleichberechtigt behandelt wird? Oder misst er, da prittiere ich da jetzt seine Äußerungen?
Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben uns auf dem Linux-Tag mit Marc zusammengesetzt. Wir, das sind ein paar Entwickler von KDE, ein paar Leute, die im KDE-V tätig sind, aus verschiedenen Disziplinen und auch Kubuntu-Entwickler. Marc hat gesagt, dass ihm das im KDE sehr gefällt und dass er für KDE gerne eine Plattform schaffen will. Wir haben uns letzte Woche nochmal mit Marc und vielen anderen Ubuntu- und Kubuntu-Leuten und auch Canonical, die Firma von Marc, unterhalten. Wir haben ganz einfach mal gefragt, ihr seid eine Firma, was wollt ihr eigentlich mit KDE? Dass wir uns gegenseitig lieb haben, ist eine Sache, aber ihr habt bestimmt eine etwas längerfristige Idee, was ihr wollt. Man hat uns angeboten oder einfach festgestellt, dass man dem KDE-Projekt gerne eine Plattform bieten will, auf der es sich selber komplett entwickeln kann. Das heißt, wir haben den Desktop, aber wir brauchen ein komplettes System, um auf Computern laufen zu können. Da gehört ein Kernel dazu und alle möglichen Systemtools. Infrastruktur gehört auch dazu. In welchem Sinne? Zum Beispiel Package-Archive. Canonical hat Shippit, das heißt, man kann sich CDs zuschicken lassen, wo KDE einen kompletten...
Wir reden jetzt über eine Infrastruktur von Leuten, die konkret etwas tun, also einen Distributions-Beherrnismus.
Ja, und auch Mirror für Pakete, wo man sich die Software drunterladen kann. Update-Sachen und so was alles. Auch Leute, die die Archive pflegen, dass man Bug-Fixes bekommt. Canonical will uns die Chance geben, dass wir ein Betriebssystem kreieren, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Wir haben kleine zehn Jahre bewiesen, dass wir scheinbar recht fähig sind, um Software zu bauen. Und jetzt kriegen wir die Chance, um es komplett zu machen, um es so zu gestalten, wie wir das gerne hätten. Deswegen sind wir mit ein paar Leuten letzte Woche nach Paris gefahren. Wir sind eingeladen zur Ubuntu Dev Summit. Das ist eine Woche lang mit 60 Leuten in einem Hotel sitzen und zusammenarbeiten, von morgens bis abends. Und nachts dann auch arbeiten in etwas anderen Art. Wir haben uns wahnsinnig viel unterhalten. Wir haben uns sehr darüber gefreut, dass wir aufgenommen worden sind. Wir haben uns mit wahnsinnig vielen Entwicklern unterhalten, die im Software-Stack andere Aufgaben lösen, mit denen wir uns besser integrieren wollen. Das sind keine Leute, das sind Leute, die weiter am Betriebssystem arbeiten. Auch die Sachen, die nicht direkt die Oberfläche betreffen. Das Spannende ist eigentlich, dass wenn man eine Idee hat, man will Sachen ändern, dann braucht man keine Mails zu schreiben. Und die richtigen Leute raussuchen. Sondern man geht einfach zu denen hin, sagt hey, Colin zum Beispiel, Colin ist einer vom Release-Team. Wahnsinnig netter Kerl. Colin, ich habe mir da was überlegt. Und hast du da auch eine Meinung zu? Der ist ziemlich intelligent, der Kerl. Und der kann einem da wahnsinnig gutes Input bieten. Und man braucht meistens mehrere Leute, die Ahnung haben von verschiedenen Sachen. Gerade, wenn man die komplette Integration mit einem Betriebssystem regeln will. Das heißt, man kann ganz einfach zu den Leuten hingehen, sich mit denen direkt spontan zusammensetzen, Probleme erörtern, Fragen stellen und ganz einfach deren Meinung hören. Und auch Leute überzeugen von bestimmten Ideen. Und auch überzeugt werden von bestimmten Ideen. Und Leute sagen einem auch, ja, ganz okay, aber diese Sache, die habt ihr dabei nicht bedacht oder habt ihr hier eventuell eine Lösung für. Und solche Meetings, die sind wahnsinnig wichtig, um weiterzukommen. Große Designfragen sind sehr schwierig, über E-Mail zu besprechen.
Also wenn ich das richtig interpretiere, zeichnet sich auch generell in der Open Source-Gemeinde, speziell in dieser Dienungsgemeinde, so ein bisschen die Erkenntnis ab, dass wenn jeder nur weiter vor sich hin muckelt, man eigentlich nichts anderes produziert als die zehnte Variante einer neuen Sound-Laborie, aber am Ende nicht wirklich zu einem laufigen System hinkommt und das ist ja eigentlich das, womit man auch konkurriert. Also wenn man sich anschaut, wie Microsoft das macht, man mag von Microsoft halten, was man will, aber doof sind die auch nicht und sind immerhin in der Lage, komplexe Systeme zu entwickeln, das tun sie auch. Bei Apple ist es halt nicht anders. Wenn man an der Stelle eben konkurrenzfähig sein will, denke ich, ist dann so ein Top-Down-Ansatz, wo man also wirklich vom User bis unten zum Kernel blickt und mal wirklich alles überlegt, ganz wichtig. Es gibt halt so Sachen, die einen immer wieder stören, die man eben durch solche Sachen vielleicht auch umschiffen kann.
Klar, es geht allerdings nicht nur in diese zwei Richtungen im Software-Stack, das heißt rauf und runter, sondern es ist auch sehr sinnvoll, sich auch mit Leuten auf gleicher Ebene zusammenzusetzen. Wir haben uns zum Beispiel mit ein paar Leuten von Gnome zusammengesetzt, weil die brauchen auch Tools, mit denen man Systemeinstellungen ändern kann. Ich hatte vorhin schon angedeutet, dass wir die Tools teilweise haben. Und dann haben wir uns überlegt, wie können wir da mehr Arbeit teilen? Und im Grunde genommen sollten nur die User-Interfaces sich ändern. Und am Rest können wir zusammenarbeiten. Und das werden wir noch viel mehr machen als jetzt.
Da gibt es ja auch ein Projekt, das sogenannte Free Desktop-Projekt.
Richtig. Und da werden halt Sachen, die zwischen den großen Desktops Gnome und KDE, aber auch kleinere Sachen, zum Beispiel XFCE, geteilt werden. Die werden da praktisch, XFCE ist X-Free-Destop-Environment, sowas in der Art. Die Adresse ist xfce.org.
I'd like graphical desktop environment for various Linux-Systems.
Prima. Und da haben wir auch Leute von... Und wir wollen uns Arbeit ersparen, weil, wie gesagt, wir sind alle gleich faul und wir wollen auch nicht unbedingt Bugs duplizieren. Zusammenarbeiten macht wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Ich habe letzte Woche ein paar von enormen Leuten kennengelernt und das sind wahnsinnig nette Leute. Und die wollen genauso wie wir zusammenarbeiten und die wollen genauso wie wir den freien Desktop weiterführen.
Was heißt das? War das endlich ein einheitliches User-Interface für Linux- und Unix-Betriebssysteme in der freien Welt?
Nein. Es heißt für beide Projekte schnellere Entwicklung. Es heißt für beide Projekte mehr Möglichkeiten, um sich auszudrücken und es heißt für die Außenwelt weniger Krieg.
Das heißt, im Kern einigt man sich zunächst einmal auf technische Details, so was wie Dreck und Drop und Copy-Paste und so. So Sachen, wo einfach niemand verstehen würde, warum es nicht funktioniert. Und natürlich dann auch für den User doof ist, weil wenn er das eine Programm geil findet, was unter GNOME prima läuft, aber ansonsten mit KDE arbeitet, wäre das natürlich blöd, wenn man hat so viele. Aber ich meine, das könnte einen natürlich auch ausbremsen. Gibt es da nicht auch so konzeptionelle Kriegslinien zwischen K und G und all die anderen Buchstaben, die auch eine Rolle spielen in dem freien Desktop-Projekt?
Nein. Wir haben im Moment, also ich habe gestern mal nachgefragt während meines Vortrages und in der Community vermutet man, dass so zwischen 0 und 5% der Benutzer einen freien Desktop benutzen. Und wenn wir jetzt die Hälfte unserer Energie da reinstecken, genau um 2% vom Marktanteil abzujagen, dann so dumm sind wir nicht. Wir konzentrieren uns lieber auf den Unterschied zwischen dem freien Desktop und den proprietären Angeboten. Das heißt, wir konzentrieren uns auf Windows. Und wir möchten lieber einen Windows-User zu Gnome bekehren, als uns in Grabenkämpfen zu verlieren. Und diese Einstellung, die nimmt wirklich überhand. Die Leute, die den KDE und den Gnome-Krieg lieben, die werden nicht weit kommen. Und es ist ganz einfach auch, die Leute, die es wirklich vorantreiben wollen, die schreiben Code, die gehen zu Konferenzen, die zeigen, was da ist, die arbeiten, produktiv, kreativ und nicht destruktiv. Und außerdem sind es wirklich verdammt nette Leute, sowohl bei den Gnome-Leuten als auch bei den KDE-Leuten. Wir denken 99% der Sachen sowieso gleich. Wir haben die gleichen Ziele, wir haben die gleichen Überzeugungen und sich dann über Sachen wie...
Okay, das heißt, jetzt habe ich so einen Eindruck bekommen, wohin die Zukunft eigentlich führen soll. Also kompetitiver werden im Vergleich zu proprietären Systemen, da mehr Kollaboration zu machen, vor allem aber auch mit anderen nicht destruktive Komponenten der gesamtfreien Softwarewelt. Wie sieht denn der nächste konkrete Schritt aus? Wir sind jetzt bei KDE 3 und KDE 4 ist schon seit längerer Zeit so in der Diskussion. Ich weiß nicht, ist da schon irgendeinen Release-Zeitraum absehbar?
Also wir werden im Oktober zu unserem Geburtstag ein Technical Preview fertig haben. Und das kann man sich dann so vorstellen, dass man sich mal anschauen kann, wie KDE 4 so im Groben aussieht. Es wird noch nicht stabil sein. Es wird nur die Technologien von KDE 4 zeigen, einen kleinen Einblick in die Möglichkeiten geben. Und man kann sich da wahrscheinlich eine Live-CD runterladen. Und das einfach mal ausprobieren.
Und könntest du so 1, 2, 3 Highlights nennen, was uns mit KDE 4 erwartet, was einem jetzt schon mal den Mund anfeuchten könnte?
Ja, also zum Beispiel Phonon. Phonon ist ein Multimedia-Backend, was es für alle Programme sehr einfach macht, um halt Multimedia-Inhalte zu benutzen. Das heißt, wenn ich in meinem Programm ein Video abspielen will, dann kann ich das innerhalb von 5 Zeilen Code regeln. Dann haben wir Solid, das ist eine ganz wichtige Sache. Unter Linux und anderen freien Softwarebetriebssystemen ist Hardware-Integration eigentlich immer ein großes Problem gewesen. Das ist auch so eine Sache, die wir über Free Desktop regeln. Wir wollen die Hardware-Unterstützung ganz bestimmt nicht doppelt machen. Da haben wir uns darauf geeinigt, dass wir ein Hardware-Abstraction-Layer miteinander teilen. Solid ist unsere Implementation von diesem Hardware-Abstraction-Layer. Das heißt, dass alle Programme sehr einfach auf Hardware zugreifen können, ohne dass dieser Wurschelcode, der es manchmal ist, wenn man mit bestimmten Apparaten kommunizieren will, dass man sich den sparen kann. Und dann Plasma. Plasma wird die Desktop-Engine und die wird einerseits den KDE Desktop verschönern. Es ist jetzt sehr viel Eye-Candy dazukommen. Also nicht unbedingt übertriebene Sachen, sondern Sachen, die einfach beruhigen, die etwas näher an der menschlichen Erfahrung liegen. Das heißt, weniger Block, ein weniger eckiger, statischer Desktop, sondern mehr natürliche Bewegungen im Desktop, natürliche Übergänge, aber auch viele Workflow-Sachen. Eins meiner Lieblingsbeispiele ist zum Beispiel, wenn ich in ein Durchschnittsbüro gucke, dann sind die meisten Mitarbeiter, mailen sich die Dateien hin und her. Und man könnte das anders...
Wenn sie es nicht so werden, wird Floppy disk machen.
Richtig. Und was könnte man jetzt... Also ohne Zweifel die Technologie, um Dateien miteinander zu teilen, ist da. Aber ich könnte mir jetzt ganz einfach auf meinem Desktop einen kleinen Bereich aussuchen. Und wenn ich da eine Datei ablege, dann ist die halt sichtbar für meine Mitarbeiter. Es ist falsch, es klingt total einfach. Aber was man sieht, ist, dass es wesentlich einfacher wird, nicht irgendwelchen Kram mailen zu müssen, sondern dass man ganz einfach das eben auf den Schreibtisch von seinen Kollegen legt. Dass man dem halt nicht eine E-Mail schicken muss, was total umständlich ist. Es wird sehr viel Arbeit investiert in Workflows, natürlicher, einfacher und intuitiver machen.
Okay, also alles wird gut mit KDE 4. Ich bin gespannt, weil ich eigentlich immer so ein bisschen darauf warte, wann das Ganze auch mal konkurrenzfähig wird. Ich bin ja bekannt dafür, dass ich mit meinem Macintosh ein sehr happy User bin, was nicht heißt, dass ich mit allen Details da glücklich und zufrieden bin. Aber man merkt schon, dass das Verständnis sich geändert hat. Dass der Benutzer langsam ins Zentrum der Diskussion rutscht, was ja eigentlich früher bei der freien Software einfach nicht der Fall war. Das war Apples Vorteil über lange, lange Jahre. Sie sind einfach die Einzigen, die sich überhaupt über die Benutzergedanken gemacht haben. Und wenn man sie an der Stelle angreift, dann kann das, glaube ich, nur gut für alle sein. Weil das natürlich auch dann wiederum Auswirkungen hat. Weil es dann auch endlich mal ein Feld gibt, in dem mal neue Benutzerkonzepte, also Benutzerführungskonzepte und Workflows auch ausprobiert werden können auf gleicher Augenhöhe. Und das finde ich persönlich natürlich auch sehr schön. Eine Frage habe ich noch. Es ist vor einiger Zeit eine Kooperation mit der Wikipedia groß angekündigt worden. Also schon auf dem vorletzten Linux-Tag war das bisher. Hat das, glaube ich, relativ wenig sichtbare Ergebnisse erzielt. Wird da noch was kommen? Ist da noch etwas zu erwarten?
Also die ersten Ergebnisse sind ganz konkret hier in Bonn. In Bonn wird gearbeitet an einem Interface für MediaWiki. Das heißt, für die Software, die Wikipedia benutzt, sodass Applikationsentwickler einfach auf Wikipedia-Content zugreifen können. Das ist, wie gesagt, in Entwicklung. Und da ist auf jeden Fall mehr zu erwarten. Und dieser Computer als Teil des Netzwerkes, also Wikipedia ist für uns toll, weil es ist wahnsinnig viel Mindshare und für uns ist es sehr wichtig, diese freie Kultur zu fördern. Wir können da wahnsinnig viel zusammenarbeiten. Ich habe ziemlich viele Fragen und Wikipedia hat ziemlich viele Antworten. Ich kann mehr Fragen beantwortet bekommen, wenn mir meine Software sehr einfach macht, darauf zuzugreifen. Zum Beispiel Amarok, unser Musikplayer, hat Wikipedia toll integriert. Wenn ich mir meine Platten anhöre, gibt es direkt im Kontext dazu, kann ich mir Discographies, Informationen zum Künstler direkt runterladen. Das ist voll in die Applikation integriert. Es benutzt bisher noch nicht die neuen zu entwickelnden Interfaces, aber solche Sachen kann man sich vorstellen.
Ich meine, ich warte mit großer Spannung auf die Ergebnisse, vor allem deshalb, weil es auch bedeutet, dass die Wikipedia quasi maschinenlesbar wird und nicht nur im Web-Browser klickbar. Von daher habe ich auch Verständnis dafür, dass es ein bisschen dauert, aber es könnte jetzt schon langsam mal anfangen. Ich bin gespannt, wann da die Ergebnisse dann auch... Gibt es da schon irgendwas? Ich meine, funktioniert schon irgendwas? Oder ist das alles noch in Herbstwerte?
Also es ist im Moment eine Planungssache. Und was du gerade ansprichst, die Maschinenlesbarkeit, so ein Interface macht es für uns natürlich wesentlich einfacher, um die vorhin schon angesprochene Accessibility weiterzutreiben. Wir haben zum Beispiel in KDE einen Text-to-Speech-Engine und können das wesentlich besser kombinieren mit Inhalten aus Wikipedia. Das heißt, ich lasse mir ganz einfach einerseits, das kann im Moment schon Websites vorlesen, wenn ich nichts sehen kann, aber ich kann innerhalb von Applikationen Inhalte aus zum Beispiel Wikipedia aufarbeiten, sodass sie für mich einfacher oder überhaupt zugänglich werden. Und das ist, denke ich, auch eine riesengroße Chance, die wir haben, um unseren Mitmenschen da etwas mehr entgegenzukommen.
Auf jeden Fall. Und wo ich auch für alle dann wiederum einen großen Vorteil sehe, in dem Moment könnte man natürlich auch generell MediaWiki verwenden als Hilfesystem. Und jeder, der ein Wiki benutzen kann, könnte sozusagen gleich ein komplettes Hilfe-Backend für was auch immer bauen. Das Problem ist, dass Leute nicht in der Lage sind, selber mal die Hilfe zu schreiben. Weil der User kann es meistens sehr viel besser beschreiben, nachdem er dann einmal den Weg herausgefunden hat, als das Programmierer in der Regel vermitteln kann.
Einerseits bringt es sehr große Chancen. Andererseits, das ist auch ein Problem, mit dem Wikipedia zu kämpfen hat. Man braucht eine kritische Masse, um die Qualität hoch zu halten. Und man braucht eine bestimmte Struktur, ein Review-System. Man braucht Leute, die sich darum kümmern, die Qualität hoch zu halten. Es ist eine Möglichkeit beizutragen, neuen Content anzuliefern. Andererseits wollen wir aber unsere Dokumentation, unsere Übersetzung auf einem sehr hohen Niveau halten. Das heißt, wir könnten Sachen einfacher machen. Aber das heißt nicht, dass wir bestimmte soziale Organisationsprozesse einfach umgehen können.
Es muss ja auch gar nicht die KDE-Hilfe sein, sondern generell, dass man Hilfesysteme an solcher Stelle machen kann.
Also weitgehendere Netzwerke, Integration.
Die Planung können wir den Leuten überlassen, die sich aktiv damit beschäftigen. Es sind ja eine ganze Menge Leute, die im KDE-Bereich aktiv sind. Das hat man auch hier wieder gesehen. Vorher auch schon auf dem Liedungstag. Und ich denke, das Projekt selber hat auch durchaus noch eine große Zukunft vor sich. Sebastian, ich denke, wir haben es jetzt einmal alles angesprochen. Es gibt natürlich noch mehr. Und wenn man noch mehr wissen will, dann geht man wohin, um, wenn man jetzt selber Interesse hat, zum Beispiel am KDE-Projekt teilzunehmen.
Also wenn man Interesse hat, am KDE-Projekt teilzunehmen, wenn man Entwickler ist, dann kann man sich auf einer der vielen Mailing-Listen melden. Man kann sich ganz einfach erstmal die Sachen anschauen, Sachen verbessern. Ein guter Einstieg sind die Seiten kdelooks.org, kdeubs.org. Da kann man, also das ist ein ganz guter Einstieg, da kann man mal seine Ideen zeigen, kleine Programme veröffentlichen. Und naja, man kann sich halt auch direkt neue Sachen bauen, fragen. Also wie bekommt man einen Account bei KDE, um seine Programme beizutragen? Man fragt. Und über www.kde.org findet man halt alle diese Eingänge. Wir haben oft das Problem, dass es etwas kompliziert ist, sich am Anfang zurecht zu finden. Aber Fragen ist immer eine gute Sache.
Genau, und wenn ihr auch noch zu Chaosradio was wissen wollt, dann wisst ihr, dass alle Informationen zu dieser Sendung und auch zu allen anderen Sendungen und zu dem Podcast im Besonderen unter chaosradio.ccc.de zu finden sind. Und Feedback an die Sendung, an uns, ist immer erwünscht unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Und wie gesagt, am nächsten Mittwoch, das ist der 28. Juni, geht es weiter mit Chaosradio und demnächst sicherlich auch mit weiteren Ausgaben vom Chaosradio Express. Trotz der WM-bedingten Pause, nein, das lag nicht nur da dran, aber auch das hat sicherlich hier seine Zeit gefressen. Wird es weitergehen und ich freue mich, dass ihr irgendwie zugehört habt. Bis bald und ich sage Tschüss.